i love this man i've known him for wow
15 plus years
um as a colleague and a friend and i
read my children books that he has
inscribed
nice messages to them when they were
little kids and i still read them and
i love this man uh he is my friend who's
joining me here today
because it's niners packers night and
he's uh got
long ties with bill franchises my buddy
steve mariucci how are you mooch
we should read green eggs and ham to the
kids to xander and cooper again huh i
have that video do not like green eggs
in hand
i have that video of you reading to them
in a rocking chair steve
it's amazing how they grow so fast which
by the way you told me at the time
you told me at the time yeah you know so
it happens too fast
no doubt um so okay uh by the way first
off
uh happy belated uh 25th annual 40th
birthday
to you steve so
i in my office here at home yes i have
the
a picture of uh i'm looking at it
there's a deon
rich where the heck are you you might
have went home it was the words bardia
yes dion
uh and and we had a birthday at the
network
um it says happy happy
80th birthday couch and uh
that was in 2006. yes i remember i think
it's because
i took the photograph steve i think
that's why i was
not in the picture you went home to bed
at eight o'clock right no we we we gave
you a birthday cake i think
bought from the local uh you know uh
grocery store down the street and it was
like
happy birthday coach and they spelled it
couch
close enough yes
we were just kids we were just kids then
uh you had hair and mine was black
oh my gosh let's start with this rivalry
let's spin some yarns
uh what was the first call you got from
mike holmgren
steve when did that oh my gosh
um i was coaching
at cal okay and um mike holmgren was
putting a staff together
at green bay and we had only met one
time
we had a mutual friend um and
he called me and asked me if i was
interested and i said
are you kidding me are you kidding me i
grew up a packer fan right back there
yes
and uh so that was in 1992
like in uh january or so
we had just gone to a bowl game at cal
beat clemson
in the citrus bowl and and so i had to
choose between
going to arizona state with bruce snyder
because he left
or uh you know pursuing the packer thing
and and uh
that was uh that was great to get back
near home and
coach with packers who i grew up loving
that's right because you were you're
yuper univer
uh upper peninsula of michigan right and
you used to go stare at the uh bart star
uh packers through the chain link fence
right well they were um i think you've
told me that story before
you've seen the photos i have rich i got
in fact her battery just passed away
this week i've got a picture
of me i was nine years old getting an
autograph from her battery it's right
here behind me and willie wood
and of course bart starr and paul
horning and that whole bunch in the 60s
that's
watching lombardi that's how i learned
to love football and never went to a
game because we couldn't
get a ticket or afford a ticket so we we
went and watched
training camp that was free and then you
know obviously you you walk into a
meeting room and is that where you met
farv
for the first time two
do you want to really know the no
because he wasn't
he wasn't there when we first got there
we
we started working you know you know the
story when i
met andy reid in the hotel that when the
fire alarm was on and we're in our
underwear and anyway so
um came later because ron wolf
traded for him right and and so i
remember he came up to me goes hey mooch
uh take a look at this guy named brett
favre
uh he gave me southern mississippi film
because he was with the falcons and he
only played
he only threw five passes he got in just
once you know and
through five passes so i had to kind of
evaluate them ron wanted to know my
opinion
and so i went well well i had to go back
to college to watch him play
and uh anyway so all i could tell was
that he had this
crazy wild strong arm and and he was
running around like a crazed dogs fired
up and all that kind of thing that we
we all came to to find out about him
anyway ron traded for him gave away a
first round pick
and he was a bench sitter really over at
the atlanta falcons red shirting
and then he became our guy after don
makowski got hurt
remember magic man of course magic man
domikowski and then favre and then
you're there too and so what did you
what did you learn about the packers
steve that you didn't already know
obviously you grew up loving them and i
just want to get into this rivalry and
set the stage of what
packers and what you learned in the
49ers tonight before we get to your
your memories of your favorite game
against green bay and stuff like that
the packer organization is so unique in
sport because
it's not it doesn't have an owner it
doesn't have an owner there's no robert
craft or jerry jones okay it's owned by
the community
by the city by the stockholders by the
people that love it
and it's it's so unique that way you
know a few years back when they needed
to add
7 700 seats in the end zone you know
they
they sold these 250 stock certificates
that meant nothing it was just a piece
of paper
but i bought one for brielle she was
born in green bay and they
they raised it in 30 hours i mean they
boom i mean that's
the support is ridiculous in fact um i'm
on the waiting list
for season tickets yeah there are about
120
000 people on the waiting list for
season tickets
okay with four tickets a piece that's
that's the demand there
in that little town of green bay of a
hundred thousand people it's
unbelievable
and you know when we got there with mike
holmgren
they had a kind of a two decade drought
after lombardy you know they didn't have
a lot of winning seasons
uh after after vince lombardi left and
so
it was kind of a rebuild and and uh
and mike holmgren of course ended up
winning the super bowl again and
and it's it they call it title town and
they've won more world championships in
football than any other
any other team well steve marachi here
on the rich eisen show and then i know
you went back to calm and
obviously got the the gig in san
francisco
what was it like uh being on that side
of the rivalry against the team that you
know obviously you had
so much love for and all the people on
the other side of the field
steve what was that yeah and so it was
it was weird to be honest with you
because in 97 that's when i
first took the job in san francisco and
uh of course i knew all the coaches and
all the players and all of that i knew i
knew their team
more personally than i knew the niner
team i could be
new there and we ended up playing in the
darn
nfc championship game and packers had
been the super bowl champs prior to that
and uh we actually were the number one
seed
and they came out descent to san
francisco to candlestick
park el nino we had el nino the whole
week
could hardly practice because it was
just
anyway they came in and beat us and uh
it was uh it was it was emotional
because uh you know
i i wanted to beat them in the worst way
we all did
and uh they just that's when farv was
the mvp of the league three years in a
row
and they they were just hard to beat but
you did get them
um and uh and it's it led to the highest
you've ever jumped in your life
right steve like you've never got them
in the next year
please tell the story they come back to
san francisco for a for a
divisional game and and uh that's t.o's
catch
that's t.o's catch so with a few seconds
left in the game and and i was levitated
and i got proof
with the pitcher that i just uh i was
the ball and the ball had to go up and
over the linebackers and down into t.o
before the safety hit him
and uh he caught it and we won that game
and
and uh i remember after that game was
crazy wild
uh farv came into the uh to my locker
room that you know head coach has his
own darn little locker room
and he walked in and he went hey mooch
you're looking fat
i hate your guts man and so um
it's just it was that kind of a rivalry
it's uh
and then we just kept playing each other
you know whether it was playoffs or
regular season and
and i found it very hard to beat the
packers when i was
with the 49ers to be honest with you
yeah i love that photograph of you
we've all seen it because you were you
know you've you've fed us all when you
know
pre-pandemic when we were on the road
and we would all be there and you know
brockman's in the shaking his head
you're nodding your head you've seen it
too
this is the uh for those who don't know
this is the owens owens owens he caught
it caught it caught it uh
moment and it was again the call was was
young had to get the ball
over a linebacker and drop it into owens
and obviously had to catch it and you
body language that over the linebacker
how high and
then there's a still photograph of you
getting up there how hot how
how high are you off the ground steve
that looks like uh i got to be like 43
inches i think that was like a calvin
johnson
vertex it was like a vertex
i bet you it it's a at least a foot
little more foot and three inches and i
was up like this
up in the air you saw the photo
it was awesome that was like the uh yeah
that
that you know that was against mike
holmgren too and it was kind of weird
too because of course mike's a dear
friend and he hired me in green bay but
there were rumors you know it was like
rumors his contract was up
in green bay and he was going to leave
and it was like gosh if he
beats us maybe he becomes the head coach
of the niners that's where he came from
and and uh so maybe that maybe that
win or that catch helped me keep my job
in san francisco i don't know
funny i mean why isn't homegrown in the
hall man
i mean he's got he's got a street named
after him i mean he should be he's got a
street named after him in green bay
where and and by the way he was with san
francisco before green bay just like you
were with green bay before san francisco
and then what he did in seattle i i mean
i i you know
we're talking about a franchise that
obviously we know with pete carroll and
what he has done and has been remarkable
and he's got hall of fame credentials
too in my mind
but but holmgren was the one who turned
the page for seattle first man
i mean got him into a super bowl against
pittsburgh and we know what happened
there but
mike deserves hof i think don't you yeah
and i
and i think there's you know there's
it's like some positions whether it's
receiver or quarterback or
court and coaches have a little bit of a
log jam too
and you know there are some some coaches
maybe three or four that are in line and
being strongly considered each year
based on one super bowl two super bowls
bringing two teams to two different
teams to super bowls like mike holmgren
that that's really hard
to do a very unusual so
at some point he's going to get in you
bet no doubt and then obviously his
coaching tree with reed and you and
gruden and rhodes and
you know a whole handful of of guys that
uh
that
are forget the kgb
that was another nickname that you made
up i just i don't know why
i don't know why it did i don't and i
love how you say that i don't know why
dick geron
whenever i would see him i would just
say he's kg i don't know why i would i
was referred to him as the kg dick geron
and i love the fact that it stuck with
you
but certainly in my mind i can't get it
out i don't know uh it's it's certainly
stuck with you more than the natural has
with matt ryan you know that these guys
that's out yeah you're just swinging a
miss on those quarterbacks
brockman's already shaking his head over
there they're they're just like
why does he keep going to it matt has
rejected it on every single level
every single year that since this
started and now he's trying to pass it
on
like come on rich you gotta move on you
gotta move on
well maybe think of another one you know
maybe maybe you'll hit the next one
let's see matt ryan um yeah i'm not a
good nickname giver no you know what it
is i just need to wait for another mat
to get in the league who'll accept it
that's all i'll keep going i tried as
you know with mahomes with the patrol he
didn't like that at all
um he totally matt hasselbeck
yeah i know that it doesn't work um so
what do you think right now let's talk
about the here now steve mariucci
what do you think um kyle shanahan's
thinking right now sitting in his office
maybe before tonight's game he's
thinking
why me i mean this is the most unusual
game ever in thursday night football
history
because it's like two teams that are
i don't know what's the word is it
decimated with injuries
and covids and inactives and it's like
whoa that means right here at levi's
stadium i live very close to it they
closed it down yesterday
they're playing a game tonight and and
the crazy thing is
we talked about it a lot during the
draft where san francisco just
beat the packers twice last year badly
okay it runs once in the regular season
once in the championship game
and it was like these teams aren't even
close they're both 13 and three but
the niners are a much better team and
they got better in the offseason and the
packers didn't get a receiver well
now we're playing but the niners get
this
they they outscored the packers 74 to 28
in those two games over 700 yards
of scrimmage yards and eight touchdowns
and none of those players
that got any scrimmage yards are playing
tonight
look at the running backs rahim mostert
tevin coleman
uh matt breida uh jeff wilson
they're not playing and then the
receivers let's call it kittler receiver
talked to him yesterday
and debo samuels and kendrick bourne
of course emmanuel sanders is gone none
of them are with the niners anymore
so they this is a whole new bun did i
mention the quarterback
and so it's it's crazy and then you got
the packers showing up across the
country
and they don't have any running backs uh
you know we'll see if aaron jones plays
but
jamal williams and aj dillon are covet
and so
i don't know this game is going to be
really unusual i guess the difference is
it's going to be nick mullins who's a
good young kid
uh against aaron rodgers you know steve
it's
uh i you're probably not aware of this
but i did tell the other day when tyler
irvin was named essentially the starter
tonight if aaron jones can't go running
back i did tell the story of
you asking doug marone a couple of times
or
in his mind or in his mind one too many
times at our pre-game
meeting in london just last year prior
to the jags in
texas you wondering why tyler irvin was
no longer on the receiving unit
on kickoffs
he got pissed rich what's up with that i
don't know you're just talking about
you know why i like the kid yeah he's
gonna get his feet wet
he's from san jose state yeah right here
right okay
and then we had him on game changers so
anytime we have these kids on game
changers
you get to know the kids you know and
you get to like them and all that
and i and i know he was playing and then
all of a sudden he wasn't
you know he was in the universe and then
all of a sudden he wasn't like jupiter
you know and so
i had to ask i had to keep asking i'll
tell you what steve if he scores tonight
our text
uh chain will be on fire if he actually
scores on fire yeah he's gonna score
who else is gonna score that's a great
question
who else is going to score you know and
it just makes you wonder if maybe they
should have
delayed the game a little bit here but
um i guess if you can go you got to go
in 2020
uh um especially if you know it is
entirely possible that kendrick bourne's
uh
uh initial test was a false positive
which is what matt mayoko of nbc sports
bay area is saying right now and adam
schefter
has uh has confirmed it appears that uh
the false positive means
that iuk samuel and trent williams still
have to stay on the covet 19 list just
like him because they have not had
enough testing to confirm the false
positive in time to kick off tonight
i mean this is this is yeah that's
unbelievable huh
it's real i mean we've already postponed
one thursday night game right and pushed
it to a monday that is correct i thought
they might consider doing
something like that so i'm a little
surprised we're still
playing tonight i'm glad we're playing
but i'm a little surprised
yeah there's been too many false
positives in our testing
so last one for you mooch the best team
through
eight weeks is fill in that blank the
team that you think
is the best in the nfl top to bottom
soup to nuts
all phases is which team
probably kansas city chiefs um i like
the steelers
but they can they can look
just okay sometimes i like the seahawks
i did an interview with
russell wilson yesterday which will air
on game day morning nice
sunday morning i like the seahawks a lot
but i
i worry a little bit about their defense
jamal adams is coming back
um so that the chiefs of steelers the
seahawks
and the bucks i mean the bucks just
didn't look all that good against the
giants though the other night
they beat the heck out of the packers
right and then against the giants they
flop around so
um i don't know if there's a a real
dominating team the packers can be great
at times
i don't know who do you think the bills
are coming down to earth a little bit
same with the titans well that's more
ravens are a good team not a great team
i would i would say there's a great team
out there i would go with you too steve
you know as you know i chose the ravens
to win the afc i'm genuinely concerned
about him
um but uh you know but you know and the
steelers look
amazing certainly defensively certainly
with big ben doing what he's doing
certainly with you know uh connor and
two other solid running backs and
uh right behind him and claypool looking
like what he's looking like but they
don't have outside of ben and tomlin
uh the experience that the kansas city
chiefs clearly have
and the football gods um you know if one
again knock on what if you're with me to
use a gruden phrase we'll
allow these teams to uh eventually see
each other in january because
the scheduling gods uh do not have them
facing each other in the regular season
so that would be a conversation that
we're kind of front loading to reach to
a crescendo if these two teams do face
each other maybe in the afc championship
game that would be something i'd
i'd sign for yeah that's uh it looks
like we're kind of headed on that
course right now that would be good the
the nfc is a little tougher to pick i
you know with the seahawks and the bucks
and the packers and
you never know what you're going to get
out of the saints and
rams are up and down and and we'll see i
feel bad
i some of the teams that got hit you
know there's some things you know when
you're a coach
you can control and some things you just
flat can't control
and injuries is one of them positive
covet tests another one you know all
those things
popped out another one and the
the eagles the cowboys the patriots and
the 49ers
have really been hit hard but i will say
that the niners have done the best job
of trying to you know finding a way to
win they won four games
with this decimated team already and we
can they have a tough schedule though
we'll see if they can win some more but
but uh it's been a crazy year huh yeah
another under the radar team for that i
would say is denver
denver you know losing von miller right
at the outset of the season
uh chubb um uh you know and and
and and then drew locke but you know who
who
looked pretty damn good this past week
but i just i just wanted to throw that
out
yeah there we have so many good young
quarterbacks in this league
i'm just so impressed um the league is
in really good shape
for you know for when the the older guys
step step down
they're talking brady brees philip
rivers ben you know those guys
the league is in really good shape for
superstars at quarterback
all right mooch uh love you see you
through the plexiglas on the set on
sunday
i know we're gonna have plexiglass all
year round by the way this is so great
mooch
when i speak to him you know in the
commercial break
okay he leans back
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right thanks mikey there you go take
care of yourself much we'll see
i'll see in a couple days all right
that's steve marion right yeah bye
that's what he'll do like i'll say hey
steve and i can talk to him through the
glass and it's a commercial break so i
can use a loud voice
and it'll go wow and i'm like no like
up there i'll talk to you through the
glass
the best last week was when he had the
spiderman costume on backpack
oh my god oh my god that was amazing
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here